okay so people who are joining this live
stream we are talking about food in wolf
now fur and often language and this is a
continuation of a meeting we did a few
days ago and let's start taking a look
okay
so this is this plot so this is already
an expanded version because that font is
bigger than usual this is a plot of is
that is it are we gonna call it compass
plot
I think if Amanda de little tree uses
this face but we could use something
else I mean that's not so established
it's the original name of it was the
nutrition compass if I remember
correctly it seems to make a lot more
sense to me sure we could call a
nutrition compass sure and I wouldn't
say plot cos kind of obvious it's a plot
arguably okay so what are we showing
here to avoid legend label collisions so
you originally wanted it to be much
smaller than what you saw in the last
meeting so I set it up to be smaller and
I think we had talked about doing it
down to about 120 by 120 but it got a
little tricky with lesions with two
legends and the labels which legends
these legends over here yes and so on on
the Alpha results the we only show for
nutrients but in energy value it's the
property we show multiple if you ask for
it via a qualifier and so in order for
example right exactly but so wait a
minute so this is this is in so mo from
Alpha can we in fact show these these
multi compasses or whatever we could
right now it's not set up that way but
we could set that up y know we have a
mole button for that part we can put a
more button on there I mean if there are
obvious things to add
um is vitamin is that really capital
letter that starts with I believe design
told us to use a capital letter there
it's not a question of design it's a
question of what the convention is for
vitamin which I don't know um
okay but but what's the problem but
though the read I don't understand what
the read um
outer boundary is here oh I see that
yeah that's the FDA's daily value what
are the dotted lines the dotted lines
are Mar roughly half between a month so
that's like 50% in this case so 100%
I'll use the redline and 50% of that is
where the dashed lines are look if we're
going to talk about graphics we should
get some designer here um
that seems obscure to me because I don't
make the connection between the red line
and the and the dashed grey lines go
what I'm saying the - grey lines are
supposed to be how much of the sky yeah
yeah right but if we're going to use
that it's got to have some connection if
some can we see if Jeremy Davis is
around um okay okay let's keep going and
we'll come back to this in a minute okay
um what happens when this degenerates to
a point when there's only one example
here that is what you're looking at
right now that one that your mouse is on
before that was not showing up and I
fixed an issue with it where it was just
being dropped altogether and now I have
it just make it nice and visible so you
can see it there a comma between fried
common like that's an issue that needs
to be fixed we'll talk about that once
we get to the end to put interpretation
stuff that's a separate detail okay okay
all right let's let's keep going let's
loop back to this one we get Jeremy and
we'll talk about these graphics here
okay
so you'd ask for things to be renamed
and I got most of them I think these are
just example I want to see what they
look like since then I thought we were
making these nice and small we will yes
for now I'm just focusing on the renames
those will take a little more time to
figure out the right way to change those
out okay yeah I'll make those blue we're
going to make those lines then I will
talk let's that's okay oh that's up
there okay okay okay okay book is all
input interpretation okay are you gonna
be able to get Jeremy or not okay all
right well let's go back here okay to
computer II too big okay all right so um
what okay this is the original design
yes I believe it's the first one that
you saw okay and I think we went back
and redesigned it now I wasn't as
heavily involved in the input
interpretation development so some of
the details are a little fuzzy for me in
that way but we can take a look this is
just to give you an idea of what's
available and some ideas that we have
and we can discuss those and okay all
right okay so I mean I think the point
is that we thought we might be able to
get an on computer II version here and
it isn't working because you know when I
read this it's like beans okay if I said
refried 100 grams of refried beans fine
that's a non computery kind of natural
language type version right but by the
time it's being amount a hundred grams
preparation refried it's deeply computer
a by making sense yeah at that point we
might as well put it in Nice boxes and
things and admit that it's computer and
make a benefit out of it rather than a
oh it's hard to read but now you have an
idea
so this is just a very quick and dirty
thing that I threw together is another
idea potentially to at least get us
thinking of other ways to do this that
maybe a little less computery hopefully
and real quick Jeremy will be here in
about ten minutes he's finishing well is
this a good example or is this a bad
example I mean are you going to be able
to pack the refried stuff in front of
the the actual food or not I mean in
other words do you know how to do the
ordering here is this like a a it's like
you know filings and orders and things
in other words it's not a hierarchy here
it's it's a little tricky on line that
that actually is in one of the bullet
points that I've pointed out there is
that the order of them is a little
tricky and and can really vary from
thing to thing this was just to get a
rough idea of what it might look like
you're right though that the order is is
complicated and but so what what are the
categories of thing there's about fifty
of them so it's a little complicated to
UM come up with a hierarchy or a
preferred ordering okay so what's an
example of something which has a big
stack of those guys I think we looked at
the fried chicken leg was a great
example okay can we can you explain to
me what would happen in this stacked
strings case or labelled strings case
with the fried chicken leg in the ideal
case it would probably say 150 grams of
a fried chicken leg and you can't
achieve that because you've got these
things where in the case of that chicken
leg thing the chicken like okay so let's
take a look up here
um let's see
now what good does it do us to have this
foods identify here I think that's just
the typical style of an alpha input
interpretation where they have what what
it is you're talking about and I said
well beats of having that oh I see
because this is an implicit entity of
some kind is that right yes yes if you
were to do control equals for example it
would be an implicit entity okay okay I
think we kind of need Jeremy or somebody
from design here is this is this the
stuff we're going to be talking about
basically and I really need some more
examples also of things work work gets
more ornate because I mean this looks
beautiful down here but I haven't a clue
whether that's the typical case or
whether it's going to get crazy for for
typical examples that we get in practice
from the partners this really cover it
you can't of course come up with more
examples but this this is a real life
case oh yeah but can you please tell me
what so with it this is the current
implementation yes
how would you add a property down here
would this be boxed and then you have
the property outside it possibly I was
thinking that maybe it could be on the
left and then there wouldn't be any need
for any boxes at all and you could send
calories in 150 grand Delicious apple we
don't we're naturally speaking then I
understand that but that's that's then
changing no I
we specifically don't do that because
we're trying to make clear what we're
actually computing sure I mean we can do
the box we really need some better
examples this is too simple an example
it's really impossible to tell what's
going on from this can we generate how
can we generate a more complicated
example can I go to the website or can I
go to yeah you could go to current and
you could punch in say for example fried
chicken leg that's that's probably the
best example yes these are a little
simple but given the short time I have
it now mode 2 I have to say all modems
yes fried chicken leg
are we discussing things like the
feature space plot here I didn't plan on
it but we can I guess okay so in your
new proposal that would become that
would probably just be like that top
example where it says Red Delicious
apple except it would probably be in a
perfect world it would probably be fried
meaning of preparation labels underneath
chicken being food type underneath now
part of it but there's no way you know
to do that there's no way you because
there are other things for which it
would be you know for which the pot
specifier is a prefix to the to the name
of the food right and that's why I was
thinking maybe we need that's something
I haven't dug into real deep Michael and
I had a few discussions not too long ago
about using maybe a classifier or some
or something similar to be able to
figure out the proper order with minimal
curation as finding these rules there's
there's always going to be an outlier
probably yeah okay so okay so one of
your possible ideas is it's sort of a
computer istic thing where it's things
being tagged but we are deciding that it
is not semantically meaningful to us
what the ordering is here and we are
simply going to put it in an ordering
that seems natural for humans is that
right
[Music]
yeah no I don't know I figure that
Michael can you comment or not because
this is an interesting case where as a
matter of fact even in and we haven't
really thought about doing that that is
the concept that these attributes can be
in any order
well it's an entity specifies yeah it's
one of the things where they're the
first very boxy one I mean it represents
our spirit and what we typically do even
if it's not pretty in some sense but
this is kind of what we have done in
many domains it was a little bit
slightly unwieldly in this one I suppose
also seeing it I said like this one
activity here yeah one of the reasons I
feel like that this one isn't so easy to
read is that they are basically grayed
out and not carried out maybe we need
some more shades of it possibly like
like what you really want is the
chocolate chip cookie on the right and
the hundred cam like the food type and
the added food type it's it's more
important than vision end but really
less important than the cookie and the
chocolate trip fair enough but see it
might also be the case that these ones I
mean this idea which hadn't really
occurred before of having heuristics to
decide the ordering of a big stack like
this is an interesting idea because that
could make it a lot less you know in
comprehensible because for example if
you look at the economic properties and
things okay but go ahead I honestly I
wouldn't go too far as this like this
this one I would actually I put to put
on calm on top something that we don't
do say for chemicals but for food it
seems to be more important in my opinion
and then then it becomes already in my
opinion more natural like it's
separating they are bound in a slightly
different books form than the end in
this okay
well it's interesting I mean that would
certainly be good in terms of uniformity
with other stuff so can I see examples
of these parks forms do we still have
them available somewhere
not really we have some old images I
could dig out a few more but if I run in
version 11 for no because there's
there's no way to get access to that
without doing a lot of extra hoop
jumping okay see if you can find some
images sure we still waiting for Jeremy
yes er sorry as I'm you we check in with
him again please you're holding your
sorting okay okay well let's talk about
if we're talking about some other stuff
that is a disgusting looking picture and
I don't understand the labeling here
that's not the way your plans do
labeling right correct that labeling on
top is not the way you're planning to
labeling no I don't police I think that
how what is that one I don't understand
what you're asking what I'm seeing here
is labeling underneath direct right why
is that labeling on top that's probably
because it's a single entity and I think
that's what the framework does by
default but I can change that well I
mean I don't see any point in having why
are you repeating the input
interpretation there that's a specific
item that's not the entire input
interpretation so it's different picture
for every possible input right so what
is this is this an image of something
related to this fried chicken so if you
look at the result pod there's a single
food that it matches we will change that
in four instances or something like that
and then that's a picture that we have
for that particular entity well you
don't want to repeat that whole thing
though sure we can just give what we
should say is so the nutrition facts and
everything beyond that awful that
particular instance is that correct for
the most part with the exception of
feature space plots with which show more
so the feature space plot for example if
you scroll a little bit further down
whatever the the red dot is in the
feature space plot which bizarrely isn't
appearing at all here right that red dot
is for the instance correct yes okay
let's talk about the feature space plot
sure this one is freaking weird
jeromy's okay very good by the way
there's a weird computer istic
background audio which would be nice to
avoid but anyway let's talk about this
feature space plot I mean I don't really
get it right now we talked about a
little bit last time the fact that
there's so much structure it is
fascinating but what does it mean and I
look quite if I I don't think this will
be easy to in many cases we will not be
able to understand what the star treky
means okay as I mentioned in the last
meeting - we've done a few more changes
on what we feed to features face plot
and what it produces is a little nicer
looking but there are still clumps that
are probably not easy to explain well
they mean something they surely mean
something I mean look if we just get
this version out into the product and
we've got tooltips we can look around
what this is for example I mean in this
case you know at the point where the
feature space plot draws a picture of a
chicken here you'll know the world is
coming to an end
no I don't think it's easy Steven we
make quite a few experiments
feature space but really looks at
whatever you give it for instance has no
idea about absolute versus relative like
if you have say the data are all between
100 and 102 it's still kind of scary to
use this data and it's these sorts of it
aren't really there for humans okay but
so we should give it stuff that's as
meaningful as possible otherwise you and
I have improved this yeah that's the
that's something it's seeing something
here I mean is it seeing weird
measurement kind of conventions or is is
this the leg of the chicken and that's
the the breast of the chicken
thing see what I'm saying I mean that
there's clearly a difference it's
clearly seeing some very definite
structure here so the ones that you you
see on the website right now are only
based on the basic nutrients or the
approximants you know carbs calories fat
fine but that's that's dandy but but I'm
still this thing has five regions okay
they are they might be five different
kinds of chicken meat they might be I
don't know what they are but that's
something and that's the I think that's
the goal of the labels is to try and
give at least okay can I get this in a
place where I can look at it in more
detail with with tooltips and so maybe
they may not be perfect tooltips but you
could try and get the feature space plot
property through edit eval you all right
so how would I do that go into eleven
three or whatever and then control
equals fried chicken leg
do I want eleven three or twelve Oh
probably eleven three-eighths its own
production so probably eleven three I
guess
so we pre compute these and store them
because they're at the food type level
if you want to regenerate them from
scratch you'll probably have to download
the information for the whole set of
data and then run it through feature
space plot yourself if that's what you
want to do no I want to do that the pre
generated okay so it might be easier to
just pull out the chicken one so if you
do entity food type comma chicken why
isn't that autocomplete in I don't know
and then the property is feature space
plot okay that's somewhat a completion
problem here now I don't know if the
individual foods themselves have
tooltips on them I I think if you dig
through the structure there may be an
entity there I don't remember off the
top of my head how I've had it set up
we've gone through some changes in how
the data is actually handled what the
heck is going on here there is very
definite structure here so what is it
I think we should not spend time on this
right now because we do it anyway
iti spent quite a while this element and
this element I have a pretty good idea
which one should come together in
frequency the result from future space
but is not what makes human sense so so
you're saying if I do this too I mean
like like with element data what's a
convenient way to do it yeah it'll be
good I mean are you basically saying
because I mean that that will be a
question for the machine learning folk
yeah this cousin wisdom I mean cuz this
sure looks like this structure here I
mean I don't know my chickens well
enough to know what's going on here
these just look completely randomly
different things yeah I mean there's a
different pieces of the chicken and
they're different the manufacturers a
it's very weird and one of the reasons
why we switch to using different
nutrients than just the proximate is I
think exactly this reason what you're
bringing up is that that it wasn't
really as meaningful when you've only
used the basic nutrients once you
actually pick out me more meaningful
nutrients to use then the results become
a little more interesting and more
nutrients to the mo meaningful and tone
Michael and I Michael you may know more
like if a certain kind of food more
let's say has the same table it is one
thing to pick out my new differences
yeah for sure you must decide from the
outside should somebody look at this
data or not because the I couldn't has
no idea about smaller knobs but wait a
second wait I don't understand that but
I mean it's like like the whole point in
feature space part if you're doing
pictures of cats and dogs the fact that
there were two cats with differently
groomed you know whiskers or something
it's not going to make them that far
apart
in the feature space plot why is it the
case that tiny changes in carbs make
things far apart here I think it is
because arrays of numbers are hindered
totally different than arrays of
quantities oh well that's probably a
mistake dimensional things and well
that's probably a mistake I mean
probably what has to happen is the
feature space plot has to conform the I
mean the first step I mean gosh maybe
what's happening here is that one of
these is measured in metric and one in
imperial something completely crazy like
that okay anyway so but but I mean that
sounds like a problem that there isn't a
correct feature extractor for quantities
is that the issue there's at least part
of it I'm sorry I'm still chewing my
notebooks I have it okay well okay fine
and II can't find it right now I can
take a look may take a little bit okay
talk about this I'd probably have a
little more handy but let's go back to
our main issues here okay let's start
off with something fairly easy this is
apparently a nutrition compass plot and
why does this one not have any red in it
Jeremy is legend says 20% so when it's
when foods in smaller amounts while the
daily values don't get anywhere near
100% daily value and so we have a
lighter gray outlined to indicate 20% it
says right there in the legend this
youth if you look okay so Jeremy what
this is trying to show is how much foods
achieve
the recommended daily values so this red
line is indicating it yes you reached
the daily value now presumably sometimes
you can go above the daily value like
here right
right yes and then for some reason we
are showing an outer boundary that's 200
percent so that's pretty weird okay so
so the main thing you're trying to get
is how does so this apparently is a 20%
generally do you understand what this
plot is showing yeah yeah and we looked
at this earlier like a month ago through
their alpha design tree cleaning so this
has been tweaked a little bit I think
it's still incompressible okay so the
main issue is I mean in this case the
20% is really a big deal right that's
not just a footnote see what I'm saying
hmm I mean there should be a great big
20% that indicates that that outer
boundary there isn't the hundred percent
line you get what I'm saying guys
I think an earlier version that I had
done something like that I think I had
something like that too but I I think it
some point someone said to remove those
I don't know I think he cleaned up a
little nicer but yeah I may have also
gotten rid of some of the readability
yeah I mean I think this should be we
should not need a legend
okay sure in some kind of footnote but
what we need to do here what would
happen okay so let's imagine that we
simply
see um okay what about the possibility
of having
I'm thinking you know color exterior to
this hundred percent line that indicates
yes sir I mean it also doesn't really
look right to have you like you're in
the red zone now you've eaten too much
vitamin A yeah you turn I know you turn
orange if you eat too much um really
really too much vitamin A but but um
vitamin A sorry um but you see what I'm
saying it's like like you did what you
should do and you hit the red line that
seems wrong making sense
I think that makes sense yeah maybe the
colors just need to be changed a bit
well arguably it would make more sense
to put okay Jeremy helped me out single
Reds they are highlighted color so it
looks to me like this had slipped that
at the outer yellow and the red should
be the interior showing what
highlighting I agree that's the first
step okay so then then we've got these
weird fiducial marks inside right which
again are pretty weird I mean like like
the radial lines are not the same as the
as the you know as these constant value
lines right what is the role of the
radial lines it's merely to guide the
eye about oh yes that little pokey piece
represents carbs is that correct right
so it's not the same type of thing I
mean the spider doesn't have a full web
here going both ways but there's nothing
special here like them it's the case for
any compost plot
have compass blots okay we don't have it
but I mean out there in the world
okay let's take a look at what compass
plots so another name might be a radar
plot as I think I see that's that may be
more common than comes right um let's
see let's see what people have done out
there
great nutrition compass gives us that's
the name of this thing right I believe
so yes I think Michael showed me of
influence there yeah that's better okay
so that's much more obvious except it's
not telling one I mean the fact that it
has that spiderweb look is kind of weird
okay so okay so that's a typical radar
plot do you know in this Brett working
on a radar plot thing do you know who
mentioned it to him I don't know who's
working on it could we see if we can
find him and ask him I think there's an
example that uses sector charts somehow
to emulate this sort of stuff in my
experience it doesn't it was much easier
to just do it in graphics myself that's
how I have it's okay actually you know
this
this thing where the radial lines I mean
I like that scale there some or
something like that scale by making
sense
mm but it's it's very detailed but it's
also very obscured I mean so your basic
point is we need a general style for
doing these radar plots having the
percentages inside the plot is nice
though I like that
interior marking of the axes yeah but
what would we do here I mean it would it
would kind of spoil the content of the
plots to do something to do that I'd be
you just have a little pin percent
twenty percent here for the two lines
well except that except that what and
that would make it clear the extent to
which you do or do not reach the
recommended daily whatever it is yeah
which could then be in some kind of
dotted orange or something rather than
for cases that we don't meet a hundred -
we could have a duel we could have a
side by side right the full hundred we
see this little bitty you know
highlighted region and then the zoomed
version of the plot right where you can
kind of zoom in and see what's going on
yes that's possible and that would
certainly make it clearer what how close
you are or not
and I kind of like that idea because it
seems relevant to do that unless it's so
small in the middle that the thing just
you know it typically does look that way
though that's the reason why we put the
zoom in because originally we had
hard-coded it to stay it like 150 or
maybe even 100 or something like that
but most of the time it was unreadable
it just looked like a little dot it was
really hard to tell what was bigger and
smaller at that scale I don't know
whether it's better to have vertical or
horizontal things and it's a pity when
these things
yes it's a pity that they get obscured
like this
looks like a lot of people are doing
them vertical well this cobweb look
seems to be a very common thing um yeah
I think I mean I think we'd be you know
I also don't quite understand why the
interior is gray so we're gonna have a
red border there the interior is gray to
do grey I think we could go a shade of
red right English coloured but we could
it better right um and then you know
with the with the RDA being whatever
they're now called Divi being um some
kind of orange or something version of
these other lines which you know I don't
know whether this dashing really helps
us I think just a light gray would do
better than the dashing on the radially
outward ones yeah I'm thinking both for
the radial ones and for the I mean given
that most people seem to cobweb it sort
of equally with the radial and azimuthal
um we could probably try that and then
we need a scale
now in the way you're doing these plots
you always have a vertical line right
but you're not necessarily having a
horizontal line correct yeah I think
that was the goal is to have a flat
piece on the bottom yeah you're much
more painful left right in Uptown
symmetries yeah I wish we didn't I mean
I wish we had a way to take the scale
and put it outside the plot but I think
that will be even more obscure maybe we
could have a couple mark I'll say 25%
50% 75% of the markers in the plot and
and have the explanation of the morgels
in the legend it's a little overkill but
it would allow it to achieve well so
what we do is have have horizontal
markers in here horizontal ticks in here
and then on the edge have the ticks go
you see it's not going to look right it
that's not going to look like because
it's not going to be some obviously this
plot is symmetric is its CN or DN yes
quite
what do we do with that with the plot
labels for polar plots I think we just
go right on top right I mean we don't we
don't try to avoid yeah we're just
having the the Palmetto
Kludd I think what you want is the
feeling yeah PC that's not right because
this is this is trying to label it's no
it's a polar plot that we want because
we're trying to label the the radius
right now easier okay um well are there
any solutions I mean look if we just
look through other people's versions of
radar plots we're basically seeing the
same non solution over and over again
we're seeing this but clearly these
people are not you know I think less
clearly they're not um you know they're
not filling in the interior here and
folks like
just over over going over but that one
is better a lot of these have really
generous offsets for the labels the
percentages seems like you want to be
really tight what in looks like this one
yeah that one's better at least it's
really tight to the line that it's
labeling why even labeling why you're
not putting the percentages up on the
doesn't work it's also to digest well
the alternative would be to pick a round
number for the outer boundary here and
just label it in big that's not gonna
work you have to indicate to people this
is a that this is a scale what about
having the current idea not idea art
emote are dashed ones of different
colors and have a legend for for the
number people are not like good at
recognizing colors and it's gonna look
like a rainbow what are you talking
about there's no side area I mean the
bad area would be you're not getting
enough vitamin C or something right or
too much I mean what despair is relative
to much as pet and two litters also bed
yeah well so yeah but red is not the
right color for that so that's that's
will use red as the highlight color here
everything is green what are you talking
about I mean if you don't eat enough you
know vitamin C or something you'll
eventually get scurvy right right so so
so it's not good if you have too little
vitamin C um and for a lot of nutrients
the other extreme is also very bad too
so it's kind of a Goldilocks zone right
around the eye so let's color it gold
and then we'll be good
okay but but so I think we should try
making these continuous not - but light
gray um and I think the number of them
how many of them do we want to have
going out radially obviously in
different cases like here you're only
showing the 50% lines which i think is
completely obscure and I think we do
better showing multiple you know lines
cuz it makes it a little clearer what
they are otherwise there might be some
completely different kind of thing right
so I would I would show like on the
order of four or five radio you know
points just like you are in this case
here I'm a little worried that if the
plot stays this size that it's gonna be
difficult to read I mean what to read
the entire plot and the labels where the
the new lines that you want to have put
in are no I'm just suggesting instead of
dashed lines which are very distracting
right these be light gray lines sure
solid so that'll be fine but but now the
question is the only thing we're trying
to resolve is where we put the the
numbers in and I think we should try
running them up a vertical axis here
where we have that a solid gray and we
have tick marks on it that's what I
would recommend trying let's try that
and let's remove the caption here so
they're they're only tick marks there's
no numbers on them the numbers as well
numbers as well okay and you want to
have like five of them so twenty forty
sixty we don't necessarily have to mark
all of them and we could mark okay just
like every other one maybe see what we
don't have to mark I think it's obvious
and then maybe 25 50 75 hundred yeah
that's fine sure okay onward we go okay
this plot
so
that one is fine but now the question
here is when we have only a single point
here why isn't that just a single
width:0 object why is there any width
there I put some I made it a little
wider so that it was a little more
visible otherwise it looks very very
thin and kind of difficult to see
perhaps a point is better but as a quick
hack I just put some fuzz in there so
that way it would be visible I think a
point would be better I think a circular
disc of the orange color would be a
better thing to do rather than faking it
sure
like that makes sense and we should get
a certain size for that disc which I
think should be about 2/3 the height of
this thing here my suggestion Jeremy any
comments 2/3 of height of the existing
of this object
got it yeah that makes sense um ok
by the way what is this font here I
don't think that's the right font for
that
is it I mean shouldn't it be the same
label font that we're using to these
things here yeah we've discussed that I
think that's what the framework has is
defaults and I I don't know what to do
with it other than manually change it
which seems like the wrong thing to do
but I'll I'll look into that that's
that's one of those things on my to-do
list that I haven't quite got to we have
a suggestion on the live stream that I
do not understand how about having a
fixed empty space in the center making
the radar plot like a like a mobius
strip that I simply if I correctly in
the played the movie asleep definitely I
don't get but maybe something like this
evil pretend is not in the center but I
say it's like in an unusual yeah I think
that's obscure I mean I think people
have the best chance they have of
realizing that something is zero is
seeing that it's at the center I don't
think it helps I don't know what we put
in the center region maybe one thing
they're suggesting is for example the
calories that go straight up maybe
replace that so that nothing is there
and yeah I know that's true that yeah
okay so that would be a yeah I get it
right so in other words if you were to
make this be a for plot this one be a
for plot yeah I don't think that will
look very good because I think you need
to see this kind of you know gem shaped
object in the middle rather than
something which keeps open at the top I
think
yeah I agree okay um okay let's keep
going down here okay
the big thing so Jeremy we needed a spec
for these things to be thinner yeah
Chris just spec that and I think passed
it but but I just was in a meeting where
those respect to be much thinner okay
fine
oh good okay let's address the main
story okay the main story is what the
input interpretation looks like okay so
we've been doing a variety of
experiments trying to make it more sort
of natural language readable I don't
think they're working because I think we
can't guarantee that for example we have
here
this new suggestion which is magnificent
when we know exactly which order to put
things in but as soon as we're on the
chicken leg story wherever that one is
here and we we need to say you know
chicken leg we can't say leg chicken you
know we have to say fried chicken leg
which is a really weird ordering that we
cannot predict easily so we are tending
to return to our previous idea which is
to do something more similar to what we
have traditionally done which is
something like this okay but what
Michael is pointing out and again let's
see did you manage to find any more
examples of this by chance not really
no those were done by colleague and I
don't have that information handy right
now okay maybe in a future meeting we
can pull some of those out but at this
point I don't think I can okay by the
way this is the feature space plot what
is this there's a various experiments
what activity like if you want to make
it features a lot of methods based on
various characteristics what what do you
actually put in the quantities in
numbers if the numbers do you scale them
between and million marks or do you use
them between absolutes or do you use
rings so why does it matter to a feature
space plot I don't know what method it's
using but if it was Susan
multi-dimensional scaling or some such
other thing why would it matter what the
overall scales are it does meddle okay
well no doubt if it has negative numbers
it can care about that but there may be
a situation in which you know if you
know that it's only positive numbers you
can use a different kind of scaling okay
so what what are we seeing here so this
is SI base units everything in as AI
base units
well it's not completely stupid is it I
mean it's got iron cobalt nickel next to
each other it's not red yeah I see I
think the gold is a little bit far out
its tungsten really friendly with
iridium identity leathern tally I'm a
very similar that's that's right
I don't know these ones well enough to
know I'm surprised bismuth well it has
some I mean it's sort of similar to LED
but it has so this is kind of the modern
you know if Mendeleev had been a
machine-learning enthusiast what would
he have done type thing probably been
very confused um so this is based an
atomic number atomic mass density
melting point boiling point
Queen Anne hotness bright modular Sound
speed electric conductivity thermal
conductivity internal expansion to
really give a fair amount of data not
just kind of the easy ones well I think
it will be good to ask an actual
chemistry about this cuz this is not
nothing here looks obviously stupid to
me no that's not too much the point the
point is that the first one the first
plot candidate out of the box
okay let's but I I am a little bit
confused by why is manganese in with a
bunch of these rare earths I don't know
um I don't know okay let's go back
your first plot see it's the edge of the
box is really not very useful but so
that's probably because of a scale
problem but the quantities yes
potentially all right so scaling between
men and max that's very weird
I mean iron cobalt nickel always seem to
hang out together which is good and
chromium nearby and vanadium nearby
that's all good
where's potassium it's not on here I
think I only use the ones where we head
they use for all of the poverties I
mentioned nicely fine meeting data right
right right like it was something like
thread poverty so they live in some
dwelt I mention a space it is really far
from obvious what's kind at best
manifold so this is I agree it's good
example though um I mean in this case
bismuth has made it quite close to land
okay what's this
this is using rankings for each of them
yes I think that's a much more random
thing to do and indeed this plot looks a
lot more random hey that's that's
definitely not the right thing to do I
do t okay what does absolute scaling
mean good question oh yeah everything
between 0 & 1 with respect to the
largest not so obviously stupid let's
see what this does
if a copper and silver so close I mean
ports are good conductors Buddha loose
heat conductors by veto month one so
fair enough
and it does seem that iridium and
tungsten seem to hang out together a lot
on that block which I don't believe in
at all yeah I mean look
okay rhenium huh and one of them kept or
something it I'm just saying that
reading something of a feature space but
it's a touch of reading tea leaves yeah
well so when does that not when is that
not the case answer when you have
definite clustering no case if you just
have three properties because didn't be
very clear in thinking about
three-dimensional things we are very bad
in thinking in a dimensional spaces
where the relevant things sure some
baseline that if it is the case that you
have to very well separated things like
cats and dogs pictures of cats and dogs
they will simply separate on the feature
space plot but this cheating I feel like
because this is basically in principle
component space you trust therefore need
to again I search you're saying whereas
these are genuinely they're genuine
high-dimensional yeah
but in the case of foods you know what
do we believe the true dimensionality of
food space is I mean it's like you could
say okay I can make the argument look at
color space for example right you could
say oh my gosh it's infinite you know we
got we got all of these spectral
response curves and all those kind of
things spectrum spectral curves and so
on and it's infinite dimensional and
it's all hopeless but we know that for
human perception purposes three
dimensions is you know the chromaticity
plot is just fine
right so the question would be for foods
you know oh yeah this respect your
perception is probably five or six time
n tional something like the tastes of
six sour sweet and so on but with
respect to nutrients most of them we
cannot cannot detect okay well I mean
the physiological effect the question is
is the physiological how high
dimensional is the physiological effect
fifty we need we need plenty of
different yeah
elements yeah I suppose so
and if you don't have to me have a
problem yet can the absolute scale down
pika comes of them we need yes well okay
so we need to understand what those
features place blood makes any sense so
but but I think the first step there it
seems like there are two things which
are obvious issues one is dealing with
the the appropriate treatment of
quantities and units you know which
seems like that's a general problem we
should solve and the other thing we
should solve is missing data and I think
Etienne has ideas about how to deal with
missing data in these things
it seems not undoable given that we have
all these you know imputation techniques
from machine learning so in other words
when the data is missing it should be
able to implicitly impute some value
there okay let's go back to what we were
looking at before I mean this is
interesting but um okay so okay so
Michael is making the point if we take
this case really what we want to see is
that this is a chocolate-chip cookie
100 gram chocolate chip cookie and
Michael is claiming that perhaps we can
save this by having different sort of
graying conventions so to speak I mean
whatever scene you turn me was the the
foods on the left follows our standard
but it's kind of everyone when you ask
for food you know you ask for food the
beasts and an amount are already pretty
K down right now and the food type data
two types they are kinda our
classification it's not really of
relevance for the user so they could be
also play the cookie and the chocolate
chip they should stay very prominent Oh
where's the this is added food types is
chocolate chip what were you saying
about the yeah we're saying kinda like
the cookie and the chocolate chip it's
very important okay so food type and
added food types is it my opinion not so
important well which is not some oh the
labeling yeah yeah right that the cookie
is a food type is a technicality of how
we describe the vault
yes I understand I understand the fact
that it's a core core at its core it's a
cookie and it is also tagged as having
chocolate chips like there would be like
two clouds of peel it's on the liquids
beverages yes it's correct but you know
this this doesn't have to be put in dark
metals in your face yeah I agree yeah
that seems wrong so one question is in a
case like this we are highlighting the
entity with a gray book back
the recent I give me one
entity France here whereas foods on the
left-hand side here that's being
highlighted which doesn't seem all that
relevant mm-hmm
and you know I wonder what it would look
like if we highlighted the I mean may
perhaps this is wrong we're certainly
not highlighting a hundred grams in
usual cases a hundred grams tungsten
it's just see what that does
I see that just as doing that is that
what we're doing for all the chemical
stuff just saying hundred grams of I
think so there we don't have much
variety like for food we have slices but
that's not counted as an amount or is it
it is and the ordering so we've got a
couple of degrees of freedom here we've
got the ordering of these what's the
width on the and doing do we need those
I think that's the default for reverse
lookup type things if I remember
correctly but we can change those well
but wait a minute do we have things like
without is that what we're trying to
deal with in principle yes if it works
I'm not sure okay so we might in fact
need something different that uses a
collection of various suggestions
between that's a whole nother can of
worms here I think this is the boxless
version that I have included that I
don't think anyone liked for some
reasons I wasn't around for a lot of
that discussion yeah and why didn't we
like the boxless version I I don't know
the answer to that one you said it
should be more look like computable
computer dings well because we were not
able to correctly in the case of the
chicken leg or whatever we were not able
to correctly put it in a form that was
read reasonably and we won't in general
be able to do that I think that's
correct but I think for practical
purposes we can probably reach more than
99% correctness in that situation okay
so the alternative though is something
more like this look the problem is that
this is not readily readable I mean this
is not readily if it just if it jumped
out at me cookie chocolate chip 100
grams then I will be probably perfectly
happy that it had some extra structure
in it I just must have suggested by
Michel they use different grade levels
no I I know I know I know
so I'm asking I mean maybe okay so what
about the following Vee
put the current right column on the left
and we put the amount on the top you
know and then we can put paren for
another something like this but that
denies the possibility ever without
right and if we did have a without it's
a big deal I mean okay first of all is
it realistic to have without does that
there's the framework work with that you
can do those queries with an entity
value with contains none and and that's
right so I'm not sure if any parses off
the top my head that so in the case of
the in the in language version of this
right can I can I get to that um the in
language version will have its own stack
right so if I say where are you talking
through control equals are you talking
about what it produces the output I'm
not sure we spent a lot of time on that
yet but yeah but that's got to be
consistent as well right okay so this is
one where we have an original ok so
there's I mean honestly even that is a
little bit better than what we have over
here
because we're really highlighting the
cookie chocolate chip
so if I go back here okay and I say
hundred gram chocalate chip cookie
what's a modifier that I can use here
you mean want to have this bestowed meal
might work on the trough yeah okay but
notice that what this is doing is not
it's not showing a women and hand at all
it's simply showing this tag here so
what would it look like if it had it
without chains none in there if you want
to change the so if you input form of
the of the other book yeah okay so I
take the yellow bars copy paste okay now
what and you can copy that paste it in a
new cell and instead of using a list
around or instead of see it says energy
property food food type goes to food
type cookie multi click on the entity
for the cookie well let me do it for the
sure yeah you could do it on any of them
cut that out and then wrap it in
contains none and it'll need a list to
decide that contains none
huh okay well I mean that's not a bad
way to do it I think it's a little
unfortunate that this isn't you know
that this isn't centered that isn't you
know there isn't a hard line in the
middle for the colons
I don't see why we wouldn't want to do
that to Center this okay what I'm saying
okay if we would do this then none of
would it be part of the left side or the
right side right side okay and I think
it will be much more visible if we do
that because it'll break the you know
understood we have to have the parent to
be foods I mean can't it be the food
type you the parent would reduce a layer
entitled you see kind of the type is
food and food type but in the Box I mean
we're just worried about the gray box
short form though this one here yeah
when you turn into a you know box
structure we can't we get rid of the
food yeah we probably could that's
that's a different issue so you mean
yeah yeah okay so yes I mean honestly
this to me isn't that bad if we could
just render this in a nice way with
black and white as opposed to our you
know yellow box approach it seems like
we could make that work sure yeah I
think so too I think at the time when
this was originally done I think it
looked a little different I think it's
gone through a little more Design my
sense than if I'm remembering correctly
so that's probably what are we doing
with the entity instance the hundred
grams thing because this here is
recording as a hundred I mean we would
need another way to do the hundred grams
do we have what are other ways that
we've done the hundred gram thing I
think it should be on top performed a
human speaking you never put this at the
end yeah if it's not on the left and the
top is probably okay and if it's a multi
food combination we're basically just
doing plus plus plus what yeah or
alternatives bar I think for comparisons
fine
all right well look I think this is what
we should try and then essentially what
we're doing here is we're graying the
food type the added food types the
variety whatever and we're putting these
in black the cookie chocolate Chuck chip
and then whatever we're doing here I
mean possibly even this italic form
isn't bad don't know if that's the right
thing for this maybe it's a darker gray
but italic form but my suggestion that
makes sense
yeah I think that makes sense to me we
should at least try yeah I think this is
good progress actually I like this quite
a bit and I think merging the way that
it looks in the in the language form and
the woof malphur form is a good thing
all right what else do we have to go
over here I think that's all we had
ready for now being a quick turnaround
time the last time we can yeah um you
still have that notebook probably not no
you should returned it sure after all no
get this um okay we don't have
super-long here so we made good progress
yes I think so this was a good good
result and we just
don't know what to do with the features
place plot stuff I mean maybe it's a
stupid idea to have the foods on the
feature space plot I don't really know
what about a dental I think this is
really there's really hard to say like
if somebody literally order some fruit
and want some quick information they
don't have enough time to digest this
somebody really plays around I think
it's a very entertaining and interesting
thing yeah I think I just said it to you
again if you could take a look hopefully
it wasn't caught up by any spam
filtering everything oh good okay yeah I
mean I think the problem is there's so
little labeling here and I spoke with
Brett and his people you had suggested
labeling the outliers yes and they say
they had made some experiments but
because the outliers definition on the
side they run into so many problems that
the labels were cut off and makes you
put the labels so that they're on the
interior I mean they have a label
avoidance technology I think yeah
there's eight right now not a not in the
next month okay fair enough I think
we've gone over most of this that the
coming soon stuff okay so we are mostly
ready I think we're in good shape here
now this this plot here there's we
talked about this plot we what we wanted
to change okay okay okay I think a good
time okay well done guys talk to you
soon thanks bye